more than one year after louisville
police killed briana taylor the justice
department has launched a sweeping new
investigation
of that city's police department now
this is a second announcement of its
kind
in less than a week the minneapolis
police department is already under
investigation
as jeff begays reports attorney general
merrick garland says
investigators will now focus on
violations of civil rights
the federal investigation puts the
louisville metro police department on
notice that it is being watched
it will determine whether lmpd engages
in unconstitutional stops
searches and seizures as well as whether
the department unlawfully executes
search warrants
on private homes it will also assess
whether
lmpd engages in discriminatory conduct
on the basis of race
[Music]
the investigation stems in part from the
death of 26-year-old brianna taylor who
was shot and killed in her own home
when louisville police officers botched
the execution of a search warrant more
than a year ago
it was a senseless murder you know it
didn't have to happen
and she should definitely be here tamika
palmer is brianna taylor's mother
what do you think they'll find i think
they'll find a number of
problems i mean it's a system that's
been needing overhauling forever
long before brianna
the taylor family attorney lanita baker
believes federal civil rights
investigators
come outside will force louisville's
police department into long overdue
reform
[Applause]
we have changes real changes that need
to be made it's your front door
your house it's time to get it in order
louisville city leaders say they agree
but that it's not just their city
america is at a crossroads with policing
we just happen to be the city we're
talking about here today
doj sources tell me that we should
expect to hear about more of these types
of
federal investigations into local police
departments in the coming weeks and
months and by the way this pattern or
practice investigation
is separate from the ongoing federal
civil rights investigation into briana
taylor's death
tony all right jeff thank you very much